hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in 1964 it was
a simultaneous exhibition where Mikhail
tal took on the entire chess club of
Birmingham or maybe not the entire chess
club maybe the just the top 20 player
says this is a 20 player simultaneous
exhibition and here we have a game that
was deemed the most exciting game of the
exhibition I was sent to me by uh chess
historian Olympia urkan said that it was
a it was a really nice one a really rare
game probably you guys haven't seen it
so I I hope it will bring you great joy
as I have enjoyed watching it and
analyzing it uh if you wanna check out
some of vulcan's content I will also put
some of the links in the description
below yeah if you guys want to check out
his patreon page or his Twitter account
uh a lot of very very useful stuff there
now getting to the game uh tall's
opponent for this game is Philip Norman
Wallace and we do not have a a photo of
the gentleman hence the hoodie and yes
you guys are welcome to join me in
wearing a hoodie it's sort of a uh you
know if you're watching a chess game and
you know that everyone else is wearing a
hoodie while watching a chess game
chances are you will feel a sort of a
connection with the other people
watching and it will improve the
experience somewhat but uh now getting
on to the game uh it's uh quite amazing
for many many factors one uh tal had a
really really bad case of cold
throughout um at this entire
simultaneous exhibition and his opponent
is quite a dangerous one as as I
understand all of the opponents of the
Birmingham chess club were quite quite
strong and I'll had um he did not have
the easiest of times dealing with them
and especially the line that is played
here the line of the French defense is
one that Philip Norman Wallace used in
his games often it is one where you sort
of invite white the sacrifice for the
attack but it's not really good but this
time you're offering this to someone who
is Mikhail tal so a lot of very cool
things happen so let's dive straight
into it and then we're going to discuss
uh well the simile and everything that
happened a little bit more also if you
do not know the gentleman Philip Norman
Wallace is famous for inventing uh the
the English defense uh that goes D4 E6
and then after white plays C for Pawn to
B6 this is the English defense to the
d4c for opening uh and uh he had quite a
lot of success with it um he played I
mean he played many tournaments he
played like like maybe even 50
tournaments throughout his lifetime play
like several uh British championships so
uh you know he he was very strong later
on Tony miles adopted this setup and he
achieved some very nice victories with
it and even a Victor korchnoy I used it
in his candidates match against where he
defeated him very nicely with uh with
this line uh but getting back to the
game tal is uh well he does use D4
sometimes but uh in a simult E4 is the
it is the more
um a secure choice so E4 by tile we have
E6 D4 and now D5 the French defense as
advertised with Ponte E5 talgos for the
advanced variation and now Pawn to C5 we
have Pawn to C3 and still the advanced
variation Knight to C6 and now Knight to
F3 going for the pulse and attack C
capture Sundee for C captures and now
this is a very modern position you can
see this in many games being played
today only nowadays you will see
something like Bishop to B for check or
queen to B6 putting more pressure on the
D4 Pawn putting pressure on the B2 Pawn
or you will see Knight the gt7 but here
we have Pawn to F6 and this is not
something that you will see in modern
chess last time uh Pawn to F6 in this
position was used was in 2008 so it's
not a really a modern approach but uh
Philip Norman Wallace knew what he was
doing and he did this for a very
particular reason as you'll see in the
game Bishop to D3 uh we have F
characters on e5d captures on E5 and now
Bishop B4 width check and now there are
some other games that reach this
position but after tells Bishop to D2 it
is as of move 9 that this position has
never been reached again Knight Gita E7
and here uh tal just Castle sort of
inviting black the castle and that is
exactly what Philip Norman Wallace does
and it is in fact the strongest move
recommended by the engine so here he
castles and now it seems like everything
uh yeah is perfectly set up for a nice
Bishop sacrifice with Bishop captures on
H7 the Knight has free access the the G5
the queen will have access to H5 the
Knight on E7 is blocking the queen from
entering the game via the G5 and H4
squares so should toggle for this if you
ask the engine no you should not go for
this you should play A3 you should play
Knights the C3 continued development but
uh tal says uh I mean come on uh Bishop
captures on H7 with check and of course
you have to capture so King captures on
each 7. Knight the G5 with check King to
G8 and queen to H5 already preparing to
checkmate with Queen to H7 but this is
something that Mr Philip Norman Wallace
did a lot in his games he was very fond
of this line and he usually invited
white to go for the attack and he knew
how to defend this position very very
well so Rook to F5 this is the only move
that is playable for black in this
position because you have to allow at
your king and Escape Route so Queen to
H7 check came to f8 and now how can tal
continue the game well you could go for
the forcing Queen to h8 if you go for a
queen to h8 then Black Blocks with
knights the G8 and now it's a bishop
captures Knight captures you can play
Pawn to F4 and you get a position uh
where white does seem to have something
Knight H7 check will always be nasty but
uh black can play Queen to B6 checking
the H1 and not Knight to D3 with the
idea of bringing the knights to F2 and
that's um just a problem something like
Knight to H7 will be played King to F7
and now we will most likely have a
repetition here so tell of course not
interested in ending the game like this
at all goes for Ponte F4 he keeps the
material on the board and
he says all right show me show me show
me why why this is good for black so
Bishop to C5 with check uh uh Philip
shows that he definitely knows his stuff
here King to H1 and not Knight captures
on E5 as the king no longer guards The
Rook capturing the Knight is impossible
because of Rook captures on F1 but this
is what tal wanted tal gave up another
uh gave up a bit more material he gave
up the pawn on E5 just developed the
Knight to C3 and then maybe he can give
up another Pawn in the future maybe he
can bring the Rook to E1 that's how top
played chess and here if uh Wallace
finds a knight to F7 Tao will indeed
have a very very difficult game
although tall would find poison in any
position so who knows how this might
have end up uh so Knights the G4 was
played in the game and now Tau just
plays Pawn to H3 he invites Knight to F2
with Chuck and now how do you play this
tal again doesn't want to oversimplify
the position and he just plays King to
H2 Rook captures on F2 is fine for white
and it's even a spectacular variation so
I'm going to show it to you if Rook
captures an F2 Bishop captures an F2 and
now Pawn to G4 it seems that black is
definitely in trouble especially if you
play Rook to F6 it seems like you can
play this but look at this now Queen to
h8 with check Knight the G8 and now look
this Knight seat the E4 attacks The Rook
uh attacks the bishop and have to
attacks The Rook also Bishop this bishop
the B for check is the main threat so
you have to stop the main threat Pawn to
A5 now Knight the H7 check now The Rook
is attacked twice by both Knights King
to F7 and now Knight eat the G 5 with
check King E7 Queen captures and G7 King
to D6 and now Rook to C1 and there is no
way the black king survives on D6 with
all of the white species uh surrounding
him however the reason why tal didn't
play this is that because after Rook
captures an F2 Bishop captures in G4
there's this very nasty Rook to F7 move
it's uh I mean it looks really ugly but
uh black can play it and black can
actually defend this if Queen H5
threatening Checkmate you can play G6
and if Queen to each a to check now now
you play Knights the G8 and now okay
Knight captures and F7 King captures
Queen to H7 check King to f8 even
Knights the E4 again going for uh Bishop
to C5 with Chuck black can defend with
Queen to E7 and now white would have
nothing better but the trade anything
other than this would lose the game so
captures Knight captures and now Knight
captures the bishop on F2 and you get
this position where the material is
completely even five pounds each bishop
and Knight Bishop Knight Rook Kings I
mean crazy stuff here so that's what Tom
would get uh by going Rook captures and
F2 and it's a fine position for white
but tal says Nope let's not oversimplify
just yet just King H2 uh and okay Bishop
to D7 and now Philip develops a piece
and not a task is all right that's a
free move for me I'm gonna bring another
piece into the attack Rook 8 to E1 we
have Queen to C7 aligning the queen with
the King nicely also just attacking the
F4 pawn pawn to G3 by tal and here we
have Queen to B6 uh it's a a move that
definitely annoys white quite a bit it
attacks the B2 Pawn which is uh well the
the king is an H2 so you have to be
careful but it also blunders the game
completely for Phil Philip however Town
missed the idea and once you see it you
cannot believe tal would miss this idea
but okay he was uh he he was down with
the cold you know it's hard to say how
concentrated he was uh but feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what Tom missed here well I'll give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is night
the A4 it looks silly that that this
would win you the game and probably you
thought about it but you then you
thought but yeah of course tal wouldn't
miss this the idea is that the the
Knight has to be captured the Knight
absolutely must be captured and this
removes one of the Defenders of the E6
Pawn as the queen and Bishop are
defending the spawn for the moment the
problem is you can't ignore this because
after the queen moves let's say Knight
captures and C5 Queen captures and queen
E3 just wins the game I mean wins too
much material uh there's no way to
bounce back from this so uh point is
that after Knight to E4 you have to
capture the Knight otherwise you you
lose so Bishop capture sunny4 now comes
Knight captures on E6 with check and
after the king moves uh if you go here
then just Queen captures and if you go
here then comes a nice Knight captures
and G7 check Fork everything is
attacking that Rook King a D7 and now
look at this Rook captures an E7 now if
King characters you can also capture an
F5 with checks so Bishop captures now
Queen captures with check and after King
the C7 now comes again Knight the E6
check King B8 and that's it Queen E5
check Bishop to D6 and queen to h8 and
now you will have to start giving up
material before getting checkmated so
this is what Tom missed after Queen to
B6 tal just played Rook to E2 he says
all right now I'm putting more pressure
on the Knight I'm defending the second
rank so I don't really care about that
B2 pawn and here comes Knight to E4 now
trying to get rid of some of the
attackers Tao plays Knight C captures on
e4 D captures on e4 and now uh just a
nice Bishop to C3 uh there's no point in
in going after the pawn if you go Knight
captures an E4 then Bishop to B5 just uh
wins too much material and if you go for
Rook captures on e4 also not that
impressive Queen captures on B2 now
you've listed The Rook off of the off of
the second Rank and also you really want
your Bishop on this diagonal you do not
want the black queen controlling this
diagonal so I'll just shift the bishop
Bishop to D3 at the C3 defense B2 and
also threatens the G7 Pawn so Bishop to
D4 you have the countertops strong dark
Square bishop and now comes Rook back to
D1 aligning The Rook with the two
Bishops and the D file and now just Pawn
to E5 saying okay now my Bishop is
nicely defended if you capture then the
Knight on G5 hangs but that's exactly
what style does f captures an E5 it was
around this time as I understand it the
top was offered some coffee he declined
the coffee as it didn't agree really
with his cold but he did go uh to to
grab a cigarette as uh bear in mind well
this is a very complicated game this is
a simultaneous exhibition tal is playing
this game and 19 other games and on one
of the games uh tall sort of blundered
the queen against a gentleman named Dr
Dudley and then he went to grab a
cigarette to you know contemplate what
what to do next but even though he
blundered the queen was sort of a sort
of a tall sacrifice uh Queen blunder
thing uh where he nicely won by
sacrificing the queen even though he
probably blundered at uh but yeah I just
told you guys would be interested in
that uh and now after this F captures an
E5 we have Bishop captures and C3
interestingly Rook captures on G5 is
perfectly playable by black and now the
idea is after Rook captures on D4 Bishop
to E6 you do not want to lose that
Bishop on D7 after Queen h8 we check you
have Bishop to G8 and now E6 opens up
this diagonal I mean it's just so ugly
and uh very very hard to evaluate this
is uh well it's playable but who would
first who would see this who would
willingly go into this against tal and I
mean it's just a very very strange
position so in the game Bishop captures
and C3 was played as this bishop is a
very strong attacker and now tal does
not have time to recapture if tal just
gives Philip one move then Rook F2 check
and black has at least a draw so tal
goes for Queen to h8 to check we have
Knight the G8 and now we have Knight the
H7 with check here the tower was playing
against another gentleman who was also a
doctor and the one of the people in the
audience uh whispered to him to this
gentleman named Dr Young that he should
offer to treat Tao that he should offer
to cure his cold if tal gives him a draw
but pretty much on the next move when
tal arrived at Dr Young's board he
already defeated him basically he was in
a completely winning position so no such
Arrangement occurred so here we have
King to F7 stepping out of check and now
Rook captures on D7 with check with
knights the E7 now offering a full Rook
but also if you don't capture The Rook
your queen is hanging here so how can
talk continue this game well if he goes
after The Rook we already said if you
give black one move then Rook to have to
check and after Rook captures Queen
captures this is now either a draw or
black can maybe do something but with so
many pieces surrounding the blacking as
well it is most likely that this would
just end in repetition after something
like uh King to H1 Queen F1 King to H2
Queen to F2 checks so instead after
Knight the E7 thought just plays Rook
captures on E7 removes the defender of
the G7 Pawn that is the black king king
captures an E7 now Queen captures and G7
with check we have Rook to F7 and now
Queen to G5 with check King to D7 and
now comes in Knight to F6 with check and
this is where the magic happens this is
why it's so difficult to play against
Thal you are up a full Rook you have a
rook on A8 and you have one Rook more
than tal has the problem is it's not in
the game and the other problem is that
only one move does not lose the game
here for black and it's uh well now that
I've said it you probably know which
movie it is but only Rook captures on F6
uh saves the game for black but it's
again such an ugly line that I
absolutely have to show but Rook
captures on F6 now first queen to G7
with check uh King to C8 and the now e
characters on F6 we have Bishop captures
and F6 attacking the queen queen the G8
check Queen to d8 and now Queen to G4
with check now you can't move the King
again because Queen F4 check would uh
threaten the bishop so Queen to D7 and
now Rook the C2 with check with King the
d8 and now Queen the G8 with check again
black has to be very careful not to lose
the bishop on F6 Queen to E8 blocking
and now Queen the D5 with check and uh
probably we would see a repetition here
with Queen G8 check Queen to E8 Queen to
D5 check Queen to D7 and this is how you
save the game with black however after
Knight to F6 this is not an easy line to
calculate uh Philip went King to E6 and
now final he has a eight Checkmate
against the black king and he executes
it very nicely Queen to G4 check we have
to start by giving up a bit more
material King captures on E5 the problem
is if King is 7 then Knight D5 check
just picks up the black queen so your
only other move is to capture on E5 with
the king king captures on E5 and now
Queen to F4 with check King to D4 now
Queen captures on e4 with checking to C5
and here Queen the D5 check was played
and he was in this position on move 37
that Philip Norman Wallace resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here black actually gets checkmated in
some nine moves I will show it um as
it's a quite a nice one king the B4 now
you can either choose the pick of the
bishop or you can even play A3 with
check King the A4 now you will see
something like Queen the sea Fortress
King to A5 B4 check we cannot have a
game without that King the a for B5
check a discovery Queen to A5 now Queen
captures on C3 so you do win the bishop
at some point King captures on B5 A4
with check King A6 Queen to C4 check
King to A5 and now uh finally Rook D5
check forcing The Black Queen to block
check and after Queen to B5 uh just
Queen capture Sun B5 and this is how you
would end that game but after Queen to
D5 check Philip Norman Wallace did not
want to continue he congratulated tal
and tal won a brilliant brilliant game
like I said it was
um a sort of the uh proclaimed the best
game of the simultaneous exhibition and
out of the 20 games that style played
even though he was down with the cold uh
he won 16 games and Drew four games so
it was quite uh quite a spectacular feat
um uh well regarding the situation and
it was said that he received a
thundering Ovation and tal said that uh
and now he knows the strength of
Birmingham chess club and despite the
difficulties and limited time I felt I
felt I had to see your famous city it
would make me very happy to visit you
again but I cannot believe you will be
quite so kind to me next time so uh very
nice to play it by Thailand he was very
much impressed because you you can see
that this was not an easy game for him
and they had Mr Philip Norman Wallace
founded this idea after uh he sort of
invited thought to sacrifice the bishop
with the bishop at H7 check 95 King Jade
Queen H5 Jack rookie five Queen H7 King
f8 uh and all the way here uh yeah it's
uh it's very hard to say if uh if it
would be possible but there were some
other other ideas where you could have
played a little bit better like in this
particular position Knight to F7 would
uh give hard a give tal a very very hard
game so you can see that Mr Philip
Norman Wallace knew what he was doing
and he invited style to go for the
attack and he could have achieved sort
of a better position but still against
style uh
it would be it would be very nice to see
but just uh just shows you how how
strong uh Mr Philip Norman Wallace was
and remember this is only one game of
the 2017 uh games that he played
uh so yeah a lot of you were requesting
a towel game for his birthday and uh
once again thank you to olympiurkan for
sending me this nice one I
um uh always wonder you know should I
show Mortal games because I could only
show tall games they are the best uh uh
but uh you know I mean we can't just
show tall games on this channel we have
to show other games as well so thanks a
lot for sending me such wonderful one I
I think it's a new game for many of you
many of you probably haven't seen it so
hopefully now or uh you know Collective
vast knowledge on on the great Misha has
improved a little bit and also fun fact
as today is the 11th uh the 9th of
November at the the data was born 86
years ago it is also uh uh a pretty
famous date in the Chess World for uh in
other particular reason because in 1985
uh Gary Kasparov became world champion
on this exact day which I think that
would be very very happy for uh you know
for the for such such a fierce attacker
to sit uh once again on on the chest
Throne like like Gary Kasparov
uh but yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh it's uh I mean I I
very much enjoyed watching the game I
enjoyed analyzing it so I hope you guys
enjoyed it as well and uh I hope that uh
next year for tall's birthday I can also
find uh another game that maybe some of
you haven't seen uh you know to enjoy
his legacy a bit further as he is the
the sole protector of this Channel and
we are forever grateful to him uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Marcus
grabble uh Wesley the greatest James
Chambers Bradley Peterson and Robert
hovsepian for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day